hey 42 here this tower of testosterone
is Danish man-beast Peter Freudian he's
like a cross between Hodor man James
Bond the names
Hodor Hodor Hodor during his life Peter
Freudian was an arctic explorer dr.
unfollow gist zoologist journalist actor
author and generally just a badass
adventurer he is the most interesting
man in the world
and I hear he drinks Dos Equis in 1906
after studying at university to become a
doctor
freakin went on his first of several
Arctic expeditions when he was just 20
years old
Peter sailed as far north as he could
and then rode a dogsled 2,000 kilometers
north across Greenland in the perishing
cold facing hunger frostbite polar bears
and wolves it was during this expedition
not he discovered he enjoyed living like
an invincible but us in the nipple
biting cold so much that he didn't
return from his trip and instead lived
with the native Inuit people whom he
discovered in tule Greenland he lived
with the Inuit people for over two
decades during this time he married one
of their women gave her two children
killed a wolf with his bare hands when
it attacked him established a trading
base in Thule and led seven Arctic
expeditions because that's just what you
do when you were six foot seven man
Titan called Peter freaking and you wear
a huge polar bear coat to match your
incredible man beard it's written that
the coat is made from a polar bear he
killed himself but I think the bear was
so scared of freaking that it sheared
itself in front of him and left one of
Peters expeditions involved trekking a
thousand kilometers across Greenland
with a friend just to prove to him that
Greenland is not separated from the
North Pole by a river of course he was
correct
the two men nearly died during his trip
but freaking x' closest call was on a
later expedition in 1926 he got caught
in a raging blizzard and took cover
underneath his dogsled the snow trapped
him inside the sled and formed a large
ice cave around him he had unwittingly
created his own tomb it was so tight and
claustrophobic in there
that's his beers froze to the ice
beneath him meaning he had to rip his
beard off just to turn his head which of
course he did some say the testosterone
contained in Peters lost beard have
caused the polar ice caps to melt out of
fear so how did frickin escape his icy
tomb Hill not gonna believe this he
fashioned a ship out of his own hardened
feces and used it to dig his way out of
several meters of ice after escaping
Peter discovered he had frostbite of
both his legs and all of his toes have
contracted gangrene so he crawled three
hours back to base prices frozen socks
off then amputated his gangrenous toes
with a pair of pliers and a hammer
he used no anesthesia and he wasn't even
slightly pissed Peter never drank
alcohol because if he ever got into a
bar fight he could potentially punch a
hole in the ozone layer in the 1930s he
returned to Denmark wrote for a
newspaper for a while and then wrote not
one but 30 books and several scientific
papers he became a prize-winning
best-selling author because that's just
what you do when you're the most
interesting man in the world his first
wife died of the Spanish flu in 1921 but
he went on to marry a Danish
multi-millionaires daughter her parents
ran a marjorine business they liked
Peter so much that they made him
editor-in-chief of a magazine which is
still in circulation today and there's
the longest-running Danish magazine in
history
Freud can also led expeditions to South
Africa and Siberia just for the hell of
it and also because his prolonged
presence in Denmark and Greenland who is
causing a shift in the tectonic plates
freakin then wrote directed and starred
in several movies the most well-known of
which is called Eskimo it went on to win
an Oscar Nazi film director Leni
Riefenstahl attended the film's premiere
she was actually Hitler's favorite
director according to witnesses for he
can lifted her out of her seat and spun
her in circles above his head was
laughing his ass off why me
spinning Nazis is what Peter freaking
does for fun
speaking of Nazis Peter freaking was
Jewish and during the war he was a major
figure in the Danish resistance movement
hiding refugees and he completely messed
up several Nazi operations he angered
the Reich so much that they arrested him
and sentenced him to death he
single-handedly escaped and fled to
Sweden where he continued to mess up
Hitler's plans until the end of the war
come on this dude [ __ ] duggard his way
out of a nice coffin he wasn't going to
let himself be killed by a bunch of
Nazis now was he aged 60 frickin spent
his remaining years in New York where he
claimed I mean married another woman he
was a major player at Vogue magazine
he became best friend of American
superstar Mae West and bench-pressed
Jean Harlow at a party once finally he
became only the fifth person in history
to answer the $64,000 question
winning the TV game choke the $64,000
question a year later he was awarded the
gold medal by the International Benjamin
Franklin Society for his services to
mankind in opening new frontiers he then
wrote yet another book and died three
days later in 1956 aged 71 some say he
never actually died but was simply hired
to replace God because he could do a
much better job thanks for watching each
part of the tree wants to kill you in a
different organizing way the fruits it
grows look like apples smell like apples
and even taste like apples put her not
apples if you think making a murderer
was shocking you ain't seen nothing yet
it's estimated that every year in Japan
hundreds of people are wrongfully
convicted for crimes they didn't commit